[Applause]
well thank you very much for coming I
must say authors are always wondering
when they're in the very lonely business
of producing this stuff if anybody cares
and this is very nice I've been I've
been talking to talk show audiences all
over the country for the last three and
a half weeks into television audiences
and you never see those people of course
you hear them you hear their frustration
and their anger and their dismay but you
never really get a chance to see them
this is about the first live actual
human your evidence that American
democracy still exists and I'm delighted
that you're here thank you very much
I thought I would speak very briefly
about the book and especially about the
reaction that it has elicited in
Washington and elsewhere because I'm
beginning to feel that now in very
immediate and tangible ways in the
reviews and and in responses on the
shows the White House has finally taken
notice there was a formal statement
issued by the press office saying this
was a bizarre collection of conspiracy
theories and and since most of this as
you know is about the Clintons
themselves and their childhood and their
families I thought that was a rather
quaint way of describing the book in it
and its contents but I wanted to tell
you how this this began for me because
none of this was in the plan none of
this was expected I never expected to be
on the bestseller list quite frankly
there are there are authors who think
that that's not necessarily a badge of
merit that the more you sell the the
less learned you have been and I suppose
it for some that's true I'm I'm quite
flattered and
and astonish that it's done as well as
it has done because it is a large
audience it means a large audience over
over a hundred thousand books old Henry
Holt tells me a hundred thousand on
order and they they're republishing
another seventy thousand which is a very
good sign so I'm delighted at that this
book began at the suggestion of my
publisher who in famous last words said
I want you to do a quick book on the
first hundred days of the Clinton
administration this was way back in the
winter of 1993 when we all I think had
very high hopes for Bill and Hillary
Clinton high hopes that whether you were
a Democrat or Republican or independent
high hopes for change in Washington high
hopes that that all of the problems that
had been so earnestly seemingly
sincerely addressed in the 1992 election
would be the agenda of the White House
three years lady that that's a very
different reality what's actually
happened is very different from the
promise in the hope that we had three
years ago but in any case three summers
ago and I remember it vividly because it
was hot and sticky and nasty as it
always is in Little Rock I made my first
trip to Arkansas and after only a couple
of weeks there I knew that I had a tiger
by the tail a very different book that
the real story of this presidency was
not what was happening in Washington but
what had happened in Arkansas and that
the story was not Bill Clinton even in
the Maine let alone solely that the
story was also Hillary Rodham Clinton an
extraordinary woman without whom he was
and is unimaginable she really is the
adults of revision in the White House
[Laughter]
it's not as funny as you may think
and she was the adult supervision in the
governor's mansion in Little Rock though
she wasn't always there which meant that
there wasn't always adult supervision in
any case I discovered that there was a
very different story a very different
book to be had and I called my publisher
who was a dyed-in-the-wool Liberal
Democrat who had voted for Clinton have
given him money and like a lot of the
New York publishing world was very fond
of the prospects of this administration
and I said in the first of many
difficult conversations you know I think
this is a very troubled administration
it's going to become more troubled and
everything you need to know about it is
in its past if we look carefully and
closely at Arkansas you will know what's
going to happen in Washington DC and
you'll know what's going to happen in
the country that was not something my
publisher wanted to hear and as a result
I must say that in many respects this
book was orphaned I was told to go
forward but I was not told to go forward
with very much support or very much
enthusiasm and for a writer that's a
very difficult decision to make
first of all you have to ask who's gonna
pay my credit card bills you can't stay
free in Little Rock you're lucky to stay
stay there at all after you've been
there for a while you really have to
make a commitment to the notion of what
you're doing and that commitment was
complicated by the fact that I was
really coming at the Clintons not from
the right not from the conservative
point of view at all but from the left
they were even more a disappointment to
me than they were to all of their
enemies in Arkansas who knew pretty much
who and what they were so I had
fundamental personal decisions to make
about how to pursue this book whether to
pursue it what to say about the rest of
the American political system while I
was talking about them and as you read
the book you'll see that there are three
chapters about Washington
what I call the culture of complicity in
our illustrious alien capital I'm just
as hard I hope I should be just as hard
on the Republicans as on the Democrats I
do firmly believe that this political
system is at its end of century dead end
I think it's about as pre-revolutionary
as it can get without actually having
people in the streets and I think that
frankly is just a matter of time and I
hope when they do decide to take action
that they will at least do so in an
informed way and that's why I wrote this
book the second thing I want to say
about the book is that it was very sad
and hard to do this is not just the
story of the decay of a political system
or the disappointment of hopes this is
the story of two very promising young
people who began with a lot of
advantages a lot of opportunity and who
didn't just squander it
they literally sold it which as the
Greeks and Will Shakespeare and a lot of
other people know is an extremely tragic
story that's why they're called
tragedies and this one in many ways is I
think worthy not of a Roger Morris but
of a Shakespeare or of one of the the
Greek playwrights this is a very sad
story it's the story of a marriage that
went sour and wrong it's the story of
two abused children someone keeps asking
me in all of these talk shows what's the
moral of their childhood my goodness the
moral is be careful how you treat your
children they may grow up to be
President of the United States this is a
classic CD and seamy tale of the
American lower class in Hot Springs and
of the American upper-middle class in
Park Ridge and the saddest thing you can
say about the American experience is
there's not very much difference between
those two between the trailer courts in
the Cadillacs
I've been asked very often what the
essence of the book is and I think the
essence of the book is that we've got to
start over
we cannot endure any longer in a working
democracy the tyranny of money and of
special interests the power of sheer
material wealth which perverts
everything else in a functioning
democracy it perverts your freedom of
expression it controls everything you
think and do you eat you wear all of
that and it also controls your
government and the reason it has so much
power is because of your government your
government is the only Guardian against
that as every political philosopher from
Plato on is understood so this is a new
book it's the summer of 1995 but this is
a very very old story in fact it's the
oldest story on the planet finally I
just want to say briefly what's happened
to the book delightfully it's been very
mistreated and abused I say that because
if it hadn't been mistreated and abused
and ignored and generally dissed as they
put it in Washington by the mainstream
media it wouldn't have been true
everything that I wrote about the media
and about the culture of complicity in
Washington and about the two political
parties and about the intellectual
corruption of America at the end of this
20th century would not have been
accurate if my book had been welcomed
with open arms and lavishly praised and
extravagantly reviewed and recognized
for all the work that went into it I
wear every every attack these days as a
kind of badge of honor and vindication
now ordinarily I have to tell you that's
not something that thin-skinned authors
do easily I'm like everybody else I love
to be praised in reviews and the Nixon
book not so long ago just six years ago
got wonderful reviews extravagantly
raised and I got spoiled I was warned
again and again that that would not be
the case with this book and indeed all
the warnings were true this book has
been treated in a very political way
it's been welcomed not as literature but
as of polemic it's been seen not as a
serious documented history but as a some
kind of participation in the 1996
campaign I've been accused of being an
extreme right-wing er I've been accused
of being as a right-wing publication put
it a couple of weeks ago a far-out
left-winger I thought that was fairly
accurate I thought somebody had finally
wrote the book I've been call I've been
called irresponsible I've been called
fraudulent I've been called you know
unfounded in my claims almost everything
he says is suspect etc etc the
viciousness of the attacks have been an
index as a good friend of mine says that
I have drawn blood and again I think if
you read the book if you read what I
have to say about the media and about
the corruption that pervades American
life at the end of this century in every
respect economic political social and
intellectual of none of that is very
surprising quite remarkably the book is
a best-seller not because of Larry King
Live or Nightline all of whom said we
don't want to argue with you about this
we just don't want to do it not because
of any of that
but because of the American public which
as my grandmother told me a long time
ago is it is the last best hope this
last best hope business is not an
abstraction it's you hear all we've got
left
oh and I know you don't command the
resources of CBS or NBC or CNN and you
certainly don't have six million dollars
to pour into both candidates as the Las
Vegas gambling interests do but your
Europe poor powerless alienated
frustrated dismayed whatever you are
you're in and that too is the message of
the of the book I've been talking to
talk show audiences all over the United
States I have done about a hundred shows
in the last four weeks and I the voice
to prove it I start in about six or
seven o'clock in the morning in the
Eastern time zone and I finish up at
midnight or sometimes two or three a.m.
on the Pacific coast and you know the
most remarkable the most stunning the
most depressing and the most
exhilarating thing that I hear is the
same all over the country it's the same
frustration the same dismay the same
anger and the same hope this is a
country that never really gives up on
itself which I guess is the only source
of our greatness it isn't because we're
we're more enlightened it isn't because
we're more intelligent I think that's
been demonstrated not to be the case it
isn't because we produce better goods it
isn't because we're richer it isn't
because we have more amenities it really
is because we continue to have something
called a faith in ourselves that we can
do better and it reaches across the
entire political spectrum I've talked to
people in the Christian Coalition and
I've talked to people who were who were
X and maybe they're not so X communists
all over the United States and they're
all thinking and saying and feeling the
same thing which is that this democracy
has got to be salvaged in some way for
us if for nobody else don't even think
about the rest of the planet we used to
think about them but don't even think
about them think about yourselves and
your posterity well with those remarks
I'll I'll stop and I will answer any
questions you have on sources I'll
answer any questions you have on on my
my great personal encounters with the
American media a Giants of the I've
dealt with with Mike Wallace now of 60
minutes I think he should return to
vaudeville I think it was a great a
great start
I've dealt I've dealt with I've been to
the valley and and it's a valley there's
no question so I'm happy to talk about
any of that and please feel free to to
be irreverent or challenging or whatever
I believe me I'm used to criticism by an
actor yes you mean my earlier your
earlier time you mean the penal period I
was I was on the opposite track with
Bill Clinton the New York observers said
just as he was coming in I was going out
which I think is the main virtue of this
book I was a young very aspiring
diplomat in Kansas City Missouri in the
1940s and 50s I someone said you know
why did you choose the Foreign Service I
said that's the that's the furthest I
could get from Kansas City in terms of
terms of a career but I I dreamed of
being that ever since I was in the
seventh or eighth grade and I worked
very hard and I went through college and
graduate school and finally got to
Washington and I spent ten years there I
was very fortunate I had a series of
assignments at the upper levels of US
government I was in the White House very
early on within a year and a half after
coming to Washington I served in the
administration's of two presidents
Lyndon Johnson and Richard Nixon two of
the great scoundrels of our time it was
a great preparation for writing a
political biography of anybody although
I ought to tell you frankly I miss both
of them and I resigned from the Nixon
National Security Council over the
invasion of Cambodia in the spring of
1970 which which all of these right-wing
talk-show hosts have to say somehow
because it's in that press handout it
makes them very uncomfortable there
voice lowers they they actually become a
little tongue-tied they can't pronounce
Cambodia at the end of that at the end
of that sentence and I went through a
period working for for a think tank
called the Carnegie Endowment and I came
here first in the summer of 1975 to
write a book about Henry Kissinger so it
was ten long hard years in in Washington
in which I got to see I think the worst
of both parties I also worked in the
Senate for then senator Walter Mondale
who went on to become vice president so
I had a rather a rather I think
remarkable experience someday I'm going
to write about that because most of
people I was with have gone on to very
senior positions in the government much
to my distress my closest and my closest
colleague in government was Tony Lake
who is now President Clinton's national
security adviser he and I need --less to
say have not talked for several months
and all I can say about Tony is that
that I would hope he reads this book
because like so many professionals in
Washington and especially people in
foreign policy I I don't think he has
the slightest idea for whom he is
working I didn't if I had known about
Richard Nixon when I went to work for
him on Kissinger National Security
Council staff I would have resigned
before the inauguration tell you about
Arkansas well as I said on a local
interview program Arkansas is the kind
of place maybe the only place in the
country where you can leave Little Rock
wheels up with a sense of relief and you
land back in Albuquerque at the good old
Sunport and you think you're back in the
land of good government
no matter no matter how bad it gets in
New Mexico you must always remember
there is someplace worse and I know
that's difficult looking at Santa Fe at
Gary Johnson and the legislature and all
of that but but just think you could
have been in Arkansas it really is no
laughing matter because it's it's almost
a parody of what America is tending
toward it got there first and it's a
very sad tale
it's a stratified society the mega-rich
at the top a lot of poor and working
poor at the bottom a relatively small
and precarious middle class that's not
very assertive that feels grateful for
any crumbs that are swept off the table
it's a place that is run out of out of a
sector of Little Rock that I am now
being attacked for even naming called
the white Heights but it's quite
expressive it literally sits in the
bluffs above the murky Arkansas River
which is lined with chicken feces
because of what's upstream and
downstream this is a place of really of
almost frozen and stop time it's a place
that still has the essential social and
political and economic ingredients of a
19th century colony the difference here
is that do not run out of some Metropole
not out of London or Paris or Berlin
they're run out of Little Rock and by
the the large banking interests the
large mercantile interests and of course
the inevitable law firms and the
accommodating politicians who make the
system what it is
what Arkansas was and is the rose law
firm made it mustn't ever forget that
what Arkansas was and is today Bill
Clinton made it he was governor for 12
years now I I was often a sharp critic
of Bruce King but I began to think that
he was a statesman by comparison in a
lot of ways conditions in Arkansas are
arguably much worse after those 12 years
of Bill Clinton than they were before
go into the Mississippi Delta
where there are so many homes without
floors where there are so many homes
without indoor plumbing
it's 1993 94 95 where there are third
and fourth world conditions I haven't
seen conditions like that since I was in
West and East Africa in the 1960s as a
member of the NSC staff the most
thriving industry in town is the crack
cocaine house half of the kids don't
finish high school and that was the area
incidentally where almost entire classes
of young black men were annihilated in
the Vietnam draft 30 and 40 percent
casualty rates
it's a sad place and the saddest thing
about it is it's utter inability it's
like the old Soviet Union its utter
inability to face up to its own reality
I'm being attacked now by members of the
Arkansas establishment and and various
sons and daughters of the white Heights
because of course what I've said is the
is the one unpardonable sin the reality
the truth nobody ever speaks that in
Arkansas messengers are shot for the
message it's a very sad place a very
oppressive place and this young
politician who was enormous ly gifted an
enormous ly popular and had a real grip
on the faith and the belief in the
idealism of thousands of young people
who brought women and minorities in to
his campaigns as never before had an
absolutely spectacular opportunity to
change all that
she did I mean that's that's a very
serious question I don't know about Bill
Clinton's ability because I think it's
so stunted by his psychology but I do
think that that yes there was an ability
and yes there was a possibility there
was an opportunity I think the two of
them together you mustn't forget what
she was and the book talks about this
she was at for a fleeting and very
passing moment in her youth after Yale
and before Arkansas
I think of potential genuine critic of
the American system she might have done
something
she made an emotional and professional
decision to compromise herself and I
think she never looked back and that
tells you more about her character than
anything else but yes they had an
opportunity Bill Clinton in the end had
a machine that was capable of
challenging for the first time in the
history of that state the power of the
old interests and I can forgive in
whitewater I can forgive him Lots in-law
I'll forgive him Mena I'll forgive him
lots of things but I'll never forgive
him for not challenging that system for
not taking it on for succumbing to it
well it's a long story
yes book is fabulous sentence but other
presidents
during their campaigns when they were
sitting presidents and running haven't
had this flood of not just yours but a
flood of critical books what is it about
them is it the lost hopes or whatever
that makes all of this happen now well
it's a that's a question that I get
again and again and there are two very
interesting answers I think to that
which are not very popular one is that
they came along at the wrong time that
their foibles and their flaws and
weaknesses were the object of scrutiny
by this Republican conservative majority
in the country which has only had icons
to worship thus far and which is just as
frustrated just as powerless and just as
victimized as everybody else you saw a
bit of that in this 96 campaign with
path you cannon
the Republicans came within an inch of
having in the in their primary campaigns
a genuine populist revolt and it was
quashed by that by the big money and by
the media and all the rest but they
almost had it and what an irony that
they would have brought it to us and
rather than the Democrats but in any
case I think there is a genuine populist
discontent out there that focused on
Clinton and saw that there was some fire
behind the smoke and they've never let
them arrest you know a lot of what a lot
of what's been been really the most
troublesome from the Clintons began in
irresponsible extremist right-wing
accusations boy did I have a lesson to
learn just because the American
Spectator said it doesn't mean it's
wrong you know it's and it's so obvious
I grew up in an era when if the nation
said it if the New Republic said it if
the old New Statesman in in London said
it if they said it from the left you
were a commie and you were automatically
suspect and you were ostracized I grew
up in the height of the McCarthy period
I know what McCarthyism is I watched my
the city that I lived in the community
that I grew up in terrorized by that now
I find these voluntary comma czars
the of the Democratic Party these these
these little these very little men and
women of Washington DC doing the same
thing to the right and I have absolutely
I have to tell you in all honesty no
sympathy at all for the for the American
spectators political views or for the
Weekly Standard my god they're attacking
my book left and right but if but
because they said something about meaner
because they said something about drug
trafficking or because they've they have
attacked the Clintons doesn't mean it's
wrong the standard that I applied in the
book was to corroborate in the check
twice and three times over everything
they did say but if they said it I gave
them credit in a footnote especially if
they said it first
and I would have hoped that somebody
might have done that for the nation and
for the New Republic and for all the oil
and for a lot of liberal journals that
are no longer around
Charlie Z my old friend speaking of
extremist accusations could you explain
your process of and you just sort of
alluded to it briefly of reinforcing the
information you got to make sure that it
just wasn't a collection of people who
had a personal ax to grind with the
Clintons see this is a loaded question
because this is my this is my fall
partner here he and I have been out in
the out and the the trenches together
and investigative reporting so he knows
he knows the answer to this question the
answer is that you don't you trust
nobody when I went to Arkansas there was
a line of right-wingers right waiting to
besiege me with all sorts of accusations
my god the president's guilty of murder
there are seven black children waiting
to beat you here they're all they all
look a lot like Bill Clinton
I mean I I have that from them almost
from the moment I landed and as Charlie
knows and as any good investigative
reporter knows you check and
double-check and check again and again
and again every one of your sources and
of course you must deal with anonymous
sources of course you must deal with
confidential sources when I got to
Arkansas in the summer of 1993 a lot of
people who had spoken on the record just
two or three months before to the New
York Times of The Wall Street Journal or
The Washington Post were no longer
willing to speak on the record because
they had suffered retaliation in their
jobs in their neighborhoods the kids
that had their bicycles damaged their
wives had been threatened political
machines do not play softball especially
when they get to the top and many of the
people I talked to would only talk on
condition of confidentiality and that
just meant that my job was two or three
times harder that everybody I spoke to
who was a confidential source had to be
corroborated over and over again not one
but two three four times and everything
that had previously appeared in
publications whether it was the American
Spectator or the nation the New York
Times or the London Sunday Telegraph had
to be checked over and over again and
that's what takes three years to write a
book you know you don't take three years
because you're getting all these
wonderful advances from the publisher
you don't you don't take three years
because everybody's saying gee what a
terrific idea I think you've got here I
urge you on it's a very very lonely
process and it's an expensive process
and you're out there for the most part
all by yourself yes since it seems that
Bill Clinton is probably going to be
reelected do you think any the charges
or anything are going to come to light
in a second term yeah you know I think
this is going to be one of the most
haunted periods in American history and
how apt that it comes at the end of this
century I think Bill Clinton will be
reelected I think it'll be a much closer
race than it looks right now but I don't
I mean Bob Dole has it
the capacity I think for
self-destruction he looks that way
besides but don't was no rescue dole is
not an answer to Clinton the answer to
Clinton is not not in the present
political system I think you're going to
see a replay of Richard Nixon in 1972-73
I think he'll win by default as Nixon
did over McGovern and then I think
you'll see a kind of constitutional
crisis because I think it's quite likely
that you'll see an indictment of the
first lady not before the election but
after the election this independent
council is doing I think a very
methodical brick-by-brick job he's not I
don't think he's running for the Supreme
Court I don't think he's foolish enough
to think that Bob Dole is gonna be there
to appoint him the Supreme Court I think
Kenneth Starr is very concerned about
his place in history as not a Supreme
Court justice but as the Independent
Counsel in whitewater he won a terrific
victory a jury of their peers in
Arkansas I was there on the last day of
that trial I saw that jury tripping in
and out with Jim guy tucker and and jim
and susan mcdougal
they carried big black notebooks they
took notes meticulously they're the last
best hope of Arkansas but that was a
very skillful prosecution he's about to
get another conviction now in this trial
with France come in defend the bankers
that will lead right directly to the
steps at the White House in Bruce
Lindsey they'll nail Bruce Lindsey
before it's over
Bruce Lindsey was the bagman in every
key campaign after 84 we're talking
about here this the theft of the
American political process we're talking
about the stealing of democracy I'm not
just these are not just idle things I
take this rather seriously I believe
that eighth grade civics book it's been
my problem yes I have about maybe two or
three loaded questions for you I told ya
he said it took you three years to do
the research and you were a reporter and
you have to have sources and everything
someone's been fighting this for 20
years how come you came out finally
decide to do a book I looked at your
book clinched at it and it goes back to
drugs and what I'm gonna say probably
gonna maybe upset every
we the people in this room are all that
fault for one reason we turned her back
when we some of us asked for help and
now are you coming up with this and I
told some people this is he came up with
what you kind of come up with in here
and some of us like an SI D they cut our
throats why do we have drugs in America
for 30 years that when you look at the
medical and how the politicians of doing
with Nixon
Bush CIA and everything else so what
made you finally put your like when I
get assassinated well well why is it
taken so long
yeah that's a fair question you know I I
came out of the Midwest as I think as a
young idealistic patriotic American I
went to Washington I wanted to serve my
country I aspired to be a foreign
service officer and and and I got there
I got to the top of the government and
it and it looked very different than it
had looked in my eighth grade civics
class I left the government in 1970 over
the invasion of Cambodia I resigned as a
matter of principle there not very many
people who have done that I would just I
would argue that and it took me another
five years to leave the town because I
tried to keep influencing politics from
the inside I worked for a while in the
Senate then I worked for a think-tank
and as I got to the outer concentric
circles of power I realized that none of
that was really going to work and I
started in 1977 to write about
I came to New Mexico in 75 first and I
wrote my first book about Henry
Kissinger and then I wrote about
Alexander Haig and I stopped to write
about the prison riot which I thought
was a nasty little interlude here and
then I wrote about Richard Nixon I was
trying to get a handle on the post-war
American experience as you as you
described it this is my first excursion
really into the dark side oh yeah who's
a lot yeah it brings out the best and
the worst of the American public yeah I
don't I I I'm frankly it I'm always
asked how are you gonna vote well how
are you registered at all the rest
I'm really a man without a country here
in terms of politics I don't have a
party join the club and and so maybe I
was slow in getting there but better
late than never
but I'm glad you did thank you for just
hope everybody else wakes up before 2000
yes the Reform Party I'd like to have a
second party which is what which is what
Jim Hightower always says I think I
think the Reform Party is still very
much in the grip of this rather
eccentric and megalomaniacal founder who
is not it was clearly not an answer to
our to our problems whatever he had
whatever he may be for himself he's not
the answer to the to the decay of
American democracy
I think the Reform party's got real
potential because it has assembled
people who really do have the sense of
discontent but not so long as it's a
creature of Perot
I think it's got I've got to become
independent you know there are there are
six or seven parties out there waiting
to happen and they're waiting
essentially on the Democrats and the
Republicans to face up honestly to
themselves there are three or four
parties within the Democratic Party that
could form tomorrow if American women
would recognize what their interests are
that they have a misogynist in a sexist
and a rather nasty little good old boy
in the White House but they're you know
they're still they're still playing for
a couple of three appointments it's a
very sad game the American labor
movement is a is a disgrace I mean I say
that as someone who has been on the
radio sponsored by by local unions but
you know the fact of the matter is that
they're still they're still very largely
mobbed up and and they don't pursue
their own interests in Washington
they're giving thirty two million
dollars to the re-election of a man who
sponsored the most anti labor trade pact
in American history I mean this is
whatever this is it's not self-interest
they're part of that corrupt culture of
complicity in Washington and so many of
those constituent groups are the country
of course is way ahead of them way ahead
of the curve the Reform Party I think
auto auto
shed Ross Perot get together and decide
democratically what they're gonna do and
begin to field candidates you can't beat
somebody with nobody and it's as long as
this system is intact with the tyranny
of money you're going to have to get
money some other way or find a way to
wage guerrilla warfare politically now
this book only exists because it's sort
of guerrilla publishing on talk radio
and we're gonna have to come across the
old lines the right and the left are
going to have to understand that they've
got much more in common than they have
in differences we can't even debate the
legitimate political issues of what to
do about welfare reform or about the
future of America in the world or
anything at all about the distribution
of wealth in this country until we clean
up our democracy everything is loaded
every single discourse is fraudulent
because of the nature of the system yes
really want to change they all talk
about change
yeah but they come right down to it
they'd rather have the evil that they no
I I think I think that millions of
Americans would like to have change if
they could be assured somehow that it
would be painless colorless tasteless I
think they're afraid not have change
they're afraid of what it's going to
cost them and I don't have an answer to
that you know it sounds old and corny
but the people who started this country
we're willing to face up to the costs
and it's an old and silly story but you
know the reason John Hancock does
doesn't own an insurance company the
reason John Hancock is there so
conspicuously on the bottom in that
document is that he really did want King
George to be able to read it without his
spectacles and you know that's that
wasn't any joke at the time because if
King George read that he was going to
hang him we're not willing we're not
willing to pay the cost even if it's
temporary inconvenience now I I would
argue that if the American people are
really told what the cost is the
hundreds of billions of dollars but it
costs this country every year in
special-interest fixes in favors in
washington has nothing to do with being
conservative or liberal republican or
democrat its who owns whom you know the
great lobbies on K Street know that my
goodness are they bipartisan they bring
in both Democrats and Republicans
they're equal opportunity bribers
they're equal opportunity graph givers
they don't care what party you come from
they know that the American political
process is not troubled by audiology or
conviction it responds to money and
power influence i if if we're not
willing to pay the cost then it's all
over with then let's call ourselves
something else we're now we're now very
close to to what New Mexico has been
accused of being for a long time maybe
the country will catch up with us we're
now close to being a Banana Republic in
so many ways they have all the earmarks
of that yes you know that's that's a
that's a fairly right-wing fairly
conservative although these days you
know you don't know which way which way
is really right because they're all off
in different directions that's a fairly
conservative think tank in Washington
that sponsored principally by corporate
money and by a large bequest from a from
a very wealthy donor they do they do I
think some good work I mean I've really
I've had to adjust my my old prejudices
entirely about about conservative
thinking in this country because I think
they're doing the only the only creative
thinking on American economics these
days I think they happen to be wrong
most the time that still met may still
be my prejudice but but the Democrats
and the Liberals you can't find in
Washington doing any creative thinking
about anything I mean the reason Bill
Clinton's foreign policy looks a lot
like Ronald Reagan's is because it is
there was no intellectual alternative
when tony lake now articulates the state
of the world he could be reading from
one of the one of the things he and I
used to write I can say this because
having been a hack I'm qualified he and
I used to write for Richard Nixon
but you know and I'll tell you the
difference between 1970 and 1996 in
those days we sort of knew what we were
doing we were under no pretense we were
working for a Republican president I
accepted the old-fashioned notion that
he won
therefore I owed him my loyalty Henry
Kissinger hired me in the backseat of a
car on the way to the Pentagon and he
said for the presidency itself a
principle a notion an ideal an office
and I understood that Richard Nixon was
far to the right of my views but I gave
him a loyalty and I tried to give him
because I thought that was the
democratic process what he wanted and
what he deserved I did not know at the
time I thought he was suspect I knew he
had gained his power on smears and he'd
taken out a couple of good politicians
and Jerry Voorhees and Helen Douglas but
I had no idea that that he was the
scoundrel that he really was if you
write a biography to figure that one out
yes I had a question of the media I read
your book I really I've enjoyed it and
and think you're a very courageous man
for having written this the fact that
nine investigations in damina have been
stopped by Congress or grand juries or
politicians is really amazing to me but
it's not nearly as amazing as the fact
that the story that you're trying to
tell has also not been told by the media
I wondered how does the media do that
they do it very simply they just decide
not to do it and they're not well
they're they're not accountable to
anybody in the end unless there is an
economic consequence and the public
intellectually does not respond
economically the public doesn't boycott
CBS or NBC advertisers because CBS or
NBC doesn't put on a book about American
politics you live in a system where
there are there everything is
disconnected in such a way that the only
causes that really get expressed are the
causes that directly effect
the pocketbook now in fact this book is
about the pocketbook it's just a little
bit disguise it happens to be about the
most fundamental bread-and-butter issues
but it's about power and people it's one
step removed from that you could boycott
Nike for example because of slave labor
in Indonesia and the Pacific Rim and and
have a better chance of influencing NBC
or CBS than protesting about how Roger
Morris's book was handled or anybody
else's book the the system has insulated
itself very deliberately from that kind
of that kind of pressure and it works
works for them they know they don't have
to report me and when they do they can
craft it in such a way that it it looks
as if it's fairly neutral and fair but
in fact is an evasion is a
circumlocution on all of the important
issues now the New York Times is coming
out with a review this coming Sunday
which actually I want to point this out
mentions the word Mena well that may be
an historic first it also mentions Dan
Lassiter it says it says it's a very
neutral and very kind of bland review
but it actually does acknowledge that
there may have been something worth
looking at there and talks about the
possibility of a congressional
investigation or a special prosecutor
and says at one point I think in the
understatement of the century
the defendants table would be very
interesting at Mena and would be Rush
Limbaugh that's that that's the price
you pay for being the darling of the
left
Rush Limbaugh called it partners in
crime for and he held it up and I think
sales may have spurted for a while but
you know you pay a price for that too I
mean I yeah he loved it but he obviously
didn't read the chapters on the
Republicans it was a selective
endorsement yes Mena I'm sorry but is
Mena what is mean up let me give you the
the short course and then you got to
read it's only one out of twenty
chapters in this book it was an enormous
crime it began in the early 1980s it was
part of the iran-contra scandal
we were smuggling arms to Central
America and contravention of
congressional restrictions the Boland
Amendment this was against the law the
CIA was doing it in collusion with their
usual colleagues in these matters
professional smugglers and criminals and
organized crime in the United States
this is an alliance that goes back a
long long way and it's ongoing we
smuggle the arms down and in return they
came back with literally billions of
dollars of cocaine the Louisiana
Attorney General estimated once that the
main smuggler there Barry seal smuggled
back five billion dollars of cocaine
this chapter is based on the most
thorough documentation in the book book
is is I think very thoroughly documented
for a contemporary political look at an
incumbent president but in fact the MENA
chapter is the most thoroughly
documented of all mostly from law
enforcement sources from FBI DEA CIA IRS
and other law enforcement documents and
not least from a twenty five hundred
page archive of the personal papers of
the main smuggler Barry seal which I
didn't get my distinguished colleague
the investigative reporter Sally Denton
who was a who's a co-author with me I'm
happy to say on a number of projects got
scoured the country for a year and got
those papers and she generously shared
them with me we did an article for The
Washington Post which was vetted for 11
weeks and cleared by the lawyers and
were sent in type and that last minute
killed by the managing editor which is
another whole story but Mina was an
enormous crime and the the then
President Ronald Reagan instigated it
I'm sure a knew about it I can't prove
that in the book but I'm personally sure
George Bush covered it up and the then
governor of Arkansas Bill Clinton knew
about it as well condoned and looked the
other way he's confronted in a scene in
the book by one of his state police
bodyguards who's been on these drug
flights and and this state policeman is
appalled and dismayed he says you know
you know what they're bringing in
they're bringing back cocaine into
Western Arkansas they're dropping it in
drop sites around the state etc and Bill
Clinton says wait whoa whoa whoa that's
that's Lassiter Steele in effect don't
worry about it Dan Lassiter being his
principal backer and contributor a very
intimate friend who came into the
governor's mansion again and again and
again in the 1980s through miss Liza's
kitchen
through the backdoor he was waived
through by the state troopers only
members of the family very close
personal friends were allowed in but you
started to have a question the lady in
the red t-shirt earlier you said that
you can see mrs. Clinton being indicted
in this next four years or in the next
few years but with the cover-up in terms
of getting that information out it seems
like there's so much money involved how
would that happen it seems like if
they're they're almost untouchable know
that the Clintons are not untouchable
and and this is that this is the irony
of this system nobody's really
untouchable if they become expendable
for the for the system there are already
people in the Democratic Party in
Washington who are worried now about
what may happen to this ticket if
something if a time bomb explodes before
November there are a lot of people
working behind the scenes - it may not
believe this but I'm told this is quite
true behind the scenes to see if we
can't get the President to step aside
quietly before the convention I don't
think there's a ghost of a chance of
that happening there a lot of
Republicans who would like Bob Dole do
the same thing for very different
reasons I mean in one case because the
President Clinton's been to alive but on
the other case because Dole was been not
enough but she's not she's not
completely protected she may well become
expendable if it looks as if it would
endanger the the larger system and she's
only after all a very small symptomatic
actor in this thing what went on in
whitewater was was it's true fairly
small potatoes whitewater is only only
of 75 million bucks at most from Madison
guarantee Mena was a was a multi-billion
dollar operation in which organized
crime distributed drugs in every city in
this country including Albuquerque kids
in this town snip some of that cocaine
that came in on Barry seals planes you
can bet on it yes this lady's had her
hand up
if all your writing and the chances that
you've taken with your life you're an
interesting wonderful person to watch as
far as all of us taking more strength in
what we believe in and what we say but
I'm wondering how you have learned to
protect yourself against one of the
deadliest machines that there is which
is politics that's a very disturbing
question because as my friend Charlie
can tell you or my colleague Sally can
could tell you if she were here I don't
think I take any special precautions I
think there's a kind of maybe a kind of
naivete about my sense of that I guess
my own personal philosophical and
religious beliefs don't allow me to be
too paranoid about that but I think your
point is well-taken I'm told again and
again for example that that there are
now 45 suspect deaths around the Clinton
experience in Arkansas I don't believe
for a moment that the President of the
United States is involved in that I
don't think he had to be I don't think
he I don't think he would want to be I
think Bill Clinton is a tragic figure
not an evil one but I do think that
there were interests with enormous
stakes to protect and I think those
interests are there in Washington and I
think that that this system is so
profitable to so many that it will not
be challenged anytime soon seriously
challenged without great cost I haven't
thought about that very much because
frankly my the the real idols in my life
are people who didn't worry about that
very much yes sort of related to that
last question about a year and a half
ago there was a man named Terry Reid
wrote a book called compromised seemed
to be pretty well documented but I
didn't know whether to believe it or not
he seems to have disappeared has he been
rubbed out no
Terry Reid let me tell you briefly about
Terry Reid Terry Reid claims and I think
he was I think he's telling the truth
that he was a an employee of Barry seal
that he was involved in this operation
in Mena he wrote a book with a very
respected investigative reporter named
John Cummings he used to work for
Newsday in New York ed book was utterly
marginalized by the conventional
publishing world and by the media but it
became an underground bestseller a
little bit like another book I know and
it was not all that well documented I I
double-checked
Terry reads in the category of those
sources that you don't accept on face
value I know Terry Reid I know his wife
his wife grew up with my sister by sheer
coincidence in Kansas City his parents
go to the same church my parents go to
anyway I checked Terry read out two and
three times over much of what he says is
corroborate able and and substantiated
and a lot of it finds its way into this
book he filed a lawsuit a civil rights
suit against the chief of President
Clinton's then Governor Clinton's
bodyguard in Arkansas that suit was
recently thrown out in a great case of
judicial misconduct abusive power on the
bench by an ineffective Clinton
appointee of the federal bench in
Arkansas but before it was thrown out
they developed a whole series of
depositions that go into the MENA case
and almost every spoken word every word
in quotation marks in this book about
Nina is taken from those depositions not
from what some state trooper told me or
told the American Spectator or somebody
else but from sworn statements about
criminal matters in which there was a
penalty of perjury if they lied that's
that's a little higher standard than the
ordinary reporters interview no no the
chief of security on unfortunately is
his head of a federal agency in Texas
his name is buddy young and he's still
very very much alive and drawing a large
salary at your expense yes the
government was as complicitous in Mena
and receiving the benefits of drug
smuggling
and we continue to certify or decertify
countries like Colombia in fact not
allowing their president to come and
speak to the UN next month how perhaps
is it possible that the foreign contempt
like with our decertification or non our
plays with Cuba will finally push this
democracy further than perhaps it will
happen inside the country you know
there's there's no end to the ironies in
all of this all right we should have
decertified Arkansas a long time ago or
the United States you know the American
government officially of course is
waging a war on drugs this the the CIA's
realization of profits part of the
proceeds most of the proceeds went to
them all
I mean don't kid yourselves the great
families that operate these these
distribution systems are not in it for
pro bono purposes most of the money went
to the mob but a lot of money did go
back to the agency I'm convinced for
off-the-shelf operations but that's not
something anybody in Washington wants to
acknowledge it's a bipartisan scandal I
mean you know the Republicans and
Democrats both do it of course they did
it for Bob you know Bob Dole I have to
tell you again my colleague Sully Denton
turned this up in a piece we were
working on not very long ago Bob Dole
sent an investigator to Mena in January
of 1988 to see if he could get any dirt
on George Bush and Mena and we don't
know what that investigator found or
what he turned up but whatever he turned
up had to have come back directly back
lashed viciously against the Reagan and
Bush administration and therefore
against the Republicans and guess who
voted for contra aid consistently in the
1980s Bob Dole guess who supported Ollie
north Bob Dole guess who tried to quash
any Senate investigation of drug
trafficking coming back in Bob Dole this
is what Bruce King called a whole box
full of Pandora's
you cannot open this without without
consequences so you know of course
that's a travesty I don't know what the
current state of politics is in Colombia
I don't know whether he should have been
been allowed in or not my guess is that
there's such hypocrisy that we should
let anybody in this country you know no
matter what they're involved with abroad
they may raise the level of American
politics because I think it's it's a
tragic tragic irony you will not see the
CIA investigated or looked at or
cleansed or reformed anytime soon and
that's one of the great tragedies of the
Clinton administration unless the
pressure comes from outside but where's
it going to come from we can't we can't
even reform our own Congress let alone
the CIA you can't even really get you
know decent nominees for the Senate in
the house in New Mexico how are you
going to reform an agency that works as
a rogue on the you know the banks of the
Potomac with a thirty-five billion
dollar you know budget on one hand
that's open and another 30 or 40 billion
dollars that's black closed they know a
good thing when they see it any other
questions yes sir
did you comment the 92 election seemed
to be that Clinton was just anointed and
the media just marginalized all the
other candidates yeah and where Gary
Hart gets taken a picture with somebody
on his knee he's run out of the race yet
Clinton had all these scandals and it
was like whitewashed way Mike glad you
mentioned Gary Hart because this is the
only book you'll find with an index with
heart comma Gary in it because Gary Hart
plays a very important role in Bill
Clinton's campaign there's a great story
in here again which I which I got with
the help of my colleague Celie Denton
about Gary who done a lot of work on on
the Gary Hart case you know Gary Hart is
taken out not only because he's weak in
the flesh as they would say in his
native Nazarene Church I grew up in
Kansas City with those folks and I know
what weakness of the flesh is he also
was pushed
he was like Humpty Dumpty he didn't just
fall off
he was pushed Gary Hart was the most
inquiring crusading young senator
against the abuses of the CIA and
organized crime in the mid-1980s look at
the record it was not an accident that
he was pushed from that campaign when he
went out of that race when Donna writes
I'm not saying she wasn't on his lap it
was probably worse than that when he
went out of that race he was 16 points
ahead of George Bush and he probably
would have stayed there unlike Dukakis
and it might have been a different
presidency maybe even a different
country we don't know I'm not I'm not
anointing Gary Hart but it's a very
interesting story and out of that
episode comes the entire Clinton
strategy in 92 for dealing with what is
called the girli problem or the bimbo
eruptions as his as his chief of staff
called it but 1992 and that's another
whole problem incidentally when you look
at this book please this is there's a
lot of sex and violence in here but it's
not for the sake of sex and violence I'm
not I am NOT recreating a Victorian code
of ethics here for American politicians
I was concerned about Bill Clinton's
womanizing and Hillary Clinton's affair
with Vince Foster because because it
impinge on questions of abuse of power
and government authority in office he
didn't just do this as a separate thing
in his private life he did this as the
governor because he was the governor he
swept into these county fairs and into
these state conferences with these state
policemen acting as procures and then
later as guards for the trysts he did it
in an exploitation of his power and
every woman in this room knows what I'm
talking about
it's bad enough that you've got to deal
with the ordinary species of the gender
here here you've got a governor
surrounded by state cops who may control
your job I thought that was an outrage I
thought that was a breach of trust and
of office I don't care what he does in
his in his private life I don't care how
much Cokie sniffs her or what how many
women he's have involved with I do care
if that impinges on his public life
because he and he instantly becomes a
different person he takes that oath of
office he instantly incurs new
obligations to us
1992 he wasn't anointed that the water
was green the water was money they
planned it very very carefully they knew
there might be a bimbo eruption as there
was they knew Jennifer was lying in the
tall weeds they're not so tall weeds
they knew that there were a lot of
people out there my goodness there were
over a hundred possibilities there are
over 100 candidates they brought him a
list early on in 1987 he couldn't
remember most of the names that's a
phenomenon that's it that's a
pathological fact not at not a political
one but in any event they positioned
themselves with this worth and line of
credit 3.9 million dollars so when they
came out of New Hampshire number two
having suffered the bimbo eruption with
Jennifer they were prepared financially
which is the only way to be prepared in
American politics they overwhelmed their
opponents in the primaries he won Super
Tuesday and most important he won this
nomination the reason he's in the White
House tonight and not back in the Ozarks
is because he won Michigan in Illinois
and he won that despite the fact that
his money was drying up in Wall Street
and elsewhere because it doubts about
his character of the draft controversy
and and Jennifer and all the rest he won
that because the Arkansas money was
their worldwide travel that's what
travelgate is all about flooded him the
money to fly that 727 and those press
people into Chicago into Ann Arbor into
Detroit that's what that's what American
politics is it isn't what you see on the
on the tube at night it's careful
planning its money its power it's the
exertion of influence and they did it
with 3.9 million dollars from the
Worthen Bank the Stephens interest in
Little Rock
we've candy but we don't have time to
address the Stephens interest except
that the Clintons furthered them at
every every turn they play for keeps
that's the reason they're there and we
can we can laugh at them we can ridicule
them but in the end it's their country
not yours yeah let me take a couple more
questions in there and being so aware of
this political conspiracy against
democracy how do you handle the
responsibility to vote well I have voted
in every election since I was eligible
and I have I have been increasingly
thrown my vote away as a symbolic act I
voted for gene McCarthy in 1968 in 1996
I don't know what I'll do I I don't I
don't see any any alternative and I'm
increasingly of the view that that may
be a boycott is a more plausible answer
than anything else I'm reminded of that
old science fiction movie The Day the
Earth Stood Still where the the guy
comes down Michael Rennie comes down
with the saucer and he can't convince
anybody to be rational about nuclear
weapons and finally he just stops
everything and they sort of get the
message I think and you know that worked
on the Ford assembly line in the 1930s
I think of Americans boycott what if
they gave an election and nobody came I
think somebody might get the message I
think if Americans boycotted in a
concerted not just stay at home because
you're annoyed but in a concerted way or
express themselves in some way that
voted no wrote in no and the media had
to count those knows the American public
won't do it unless unless the media the
media recognizes it and I don't think
there's any chance of that happening
anytime soon you know what it would
require it would require going door to
door
it would require raising an army from
from a country that didn't communicate
with itself very well we did that once
that's a lot of fact well
natural no I what I'm talking about is
what Jefferson said you had to do from
time to time you have to contemplate
revolutionary means and and I'm not
advocating violence for a moment but I
think you've got a lot of possibilities
you could send a message to what George
Wallace not one of my political idols
used to say it very well send him a
message and I think you've got to do
that an American has not yet done that
these polls are all just sort of weak
and Wan signals yes one more
and I'm the theme of a revolution what
would you think of a new constitutional
convention and how would that come about
oh let me take a second part first I
don't I don't know I really haven't
thought about this and I've had my hands
full with it with the troubles of the
present system I think you'd have to
have some kind of new Constitutional
Convention I would hate to see this
country I mean I think we'd get
something much worse than we've got
right now if we if we let it splinter in
some kind of anarchy which is not beyond
the realm of the possible I mean I think
I think this country's frankly in many
ways on the brink of something violent
and I don't know you know what Oklahoma
City was exactly and I don't know what
the TWA the shoot-down was but I think
that is just the beginning I think
you're gonna have a homegrown terrorism
in the United States and I think it's
gonna change the politics of this
country forever Newt Gingrich is just
the epitome of what happens in the
system here's this hotshot young
professor who comes out of out of this
Georgia school and is an
environmentalist and thinks he's an
independent even though he's a
Republican because that's the one thing
to be in that district at the time and
he becomes instantly captive of the of
the larger interests and I don't care
what his personal sexual habits are how
he treated his wife and in the hospital
or whatever except again as as a public
servant I think he's just a caricature
of the system and the Republican
revolution wasn't a revolution I mean
these are all marginal issues that
they're concerned with I mean they
didn't they didn't attack any single
vested interest in Washington all of the
old fixes and favors were maintained I
mean why not cut a you know a single
mother with three kids and 400 bucks a
month I think it's a lot better than
taking on General Dynamics or AT&T or
anybody else besides that mother with
for two dollars a month and three kids
on welfare does not is not a major
contributor she will not be at newts
next fundraiser in Atlanta getting
zapped it was a part of the machine
we were talking about was he really
trying to or and he got zapped in the
process or no I think yeah I think he's
apt because everybody understood that
there was it that there was a sense of
radicalism in the Republican agenda and
that the Democrats and some of the
Republicans felt that that threatened
their survival that's the only thing and
I think there was a moderate faction of
the business community moderate in you
know in relative terms that thought this
was bad politics even the wall street
journal' turned on newt gingrich
editorially so there's a there's a real
limit on any kind of ideological fervor
you know I feel honestly I feel for some
of these Republican freshmen in
Washington who went there thinking that
they were in the service of principle I
think some of them actually believe that
doesn't take very long to understand
that that is not what Washington is
about revolution or no revolution yeah
just one more I'm gonna they're gonna
close the doors on me here I'm sorry hi
I'm explaining to militia groups and
once you've been talking about
well the militia groups are very sad
phenomenon I mean I think on one hand
they're deplorable and they're dangerous
and all the rest but you know they they
express this fundamental powerlessness
that millions of Americans feel I think
you go into these militia camps and you
would be amazed at how many people how
many economic populist you'd find these
are people who have lost their jobs
who've watched the factories go south in
so many ways who feel that Washington is
not responsive who feel the federal
government is oppressive my goodness I
agree with all of that you know they
they're they're fundamentally I think
ignorant of how much the right-wing
demagoguery has diverted them from the
real issues how much they've been pushed
off into social concerns and into into
racial and ethnic issues that they don't
have anything at all to do basically
what their well being but at heart I
think they're concerned about what
everybody else is concerned about their
safety their security their economic
well-being opportunity for their kids
I don't think militia groups are in
favor of lousy education even in
Arkansas these are the tragedy of the
Clintons is that every time they did a
reform in Arkansas ain't kind at all
however phony it was the poor people who
paid for it in a regressive tax system
and you know what they did they paid for
it and they continue to believe hoping
against hope that these politicians like
Clinton would come along and rescue them
which is what happens to a people who
are so beaten down who are so oppressed
and so unaccustomed to making judgments
critically for themselves yes one more
and that's it kind of stiff Ross Perot a
little bit and praising the ruling party
be honest with you if I sat down with a
beer with Perot I can't imagine a bunch
of different coming out of his mouth and
what's been coming out of yours the past
30 minutes and I I guess it confuses me
why you would want to I mean you're
talking about big money and and all
kinds of power here's a man who has all
the money you never need yeah and he's
trying to take on the system yet you're
you're doing this well I'm dead I'm very
disillusioned by the difference between
me and Ross Perot is that I would not
have dropped out of the race when I was
11 points ahead of both Bush and Clinton
just because my daughter was gonna have
you know smears against her at her
wedding or whatever I mean there's
something wrong with Perot I can't put
my finger on it I don't know we take
another three years probably to find it
but there's something that disturbs me
about about him I don't think he is
committed and moreover I think as a
matter of principle that wealth solving
a problem of the abuse of wealth is is
not what we ought to be about I think we
ought to be about changing the system
not not buying it in a different
direction and and Ross Perot seems to be
about buying it and making it right and
even if he were the perfect candidate
I'd worry about his longevity or about
his money
the reason Ross Perot has that money is
that there's something that says about
his fundamental values to begin with if
he were the kind of president I want you
probably would be a lot poorer but
aren't what you saying symptomatic to
exactly what you're complaining about
I mean if Ross Perot is trying to stand
up and I'm no big advocate of runs Perot
but if Ross Perot is trying to stand up
you redraw the Castro vote for no which
is a negative
than to try and join somebody who's
trying to